[Música]
bienvenidos en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados la última
oportunidad para evitar una catástrofe
ambiental así llamaron desde un
principio a la cumbre de las naciones
unidas sobre el clima la cob 26 un éxito
o un fracaso fue un encuentro que empezó
con grandes expectativas y se llenó de
llamados a la acción pero que concluyó
con pocos resultados el pacto final
firmado en glasgow dejó profundas
decepciones y hay desazón en el sentido
de que se esperaba mucho más
por parte del compromiso de los países
los activistas acusaron a los líderes de
ccoo hipócritas
una celebración de dos semanas de
negocios y bla bla bla
y bien que se esperaba de la cumbre con
26 se buscaba que los líderes del mundo
fijarán una hoja de ruta para limitar
inmediatamente el calentamiento global a
15 grados celsius para finales de siglo
pues un aumento mayor traería fenómenos
climáticos nefastos y como lo harían
estableciendo pautas para acabar
rápidamente con el uso de los
combustibles fósiles si bien esto no se
consiguió veamos qué fue lo acordado el
pacto de glasgow pidió a los estados
aumentar los compromisos para reducir
las temperaturas pero sin fijar cómo
hacerlo glasgow tiene un gran base de
credibilidad
simplemente porque todos los países
tenían que haber presentado sus
compromisos determinados para ver cómo
van a reducir justamente los los gases
de efecto invernadero además no existe
una fiscalización internacional para
verificar que los países cumplan y el
documento dice que las naciones pueden
hacer ajustes a sus planes climáticos
así la meta de los 15 grados parece una
utopía otro eje central fueron los
combustibles fósiles aunque parezca
increíble es la primera vez que en una
cumbre climática de la onu y como su
nombre indica ya van 26 que se incluyó
la discusión de regular estos
combustibles la causa número uno del
calentamiento global pero aunque para
algunos esto fue un paso histórico
realmente no hubo avances concretos no
sólo no se fijaron fechas y una hoja de
ruta para eliminarlos sino que el
lenguaje de los borradores del acuerdo
final se fue debilitando con cada nueva
versión en el chino se opusieron a la
eliminación progresivo del carbón y sólo
quedó plasmado en el pacto final que no
es vinculante que su uso se reducirá
gradualmente otro punto fue la
financiación la cob 26 debía duplicar el
financiamiento para que países ricos
destinen a países pobres fondos de
compensación porque debido a los
impactos climáticos
han causado históricamente las potencias
un financiamiento fijado hasta el
momento en 100 mil millones de dólares
al año pero estos fondos ni siquiera se
han logrado reunir
esto deja a los países pobres
desamparados porque tendrán que
triplicar sus esfuerzos para adaptarse
al calentamiento global del que en mayor
medida no son culpables al margen del
documento final se produjeron algunos
avances pero eso sí muy relativos veamos
más de 100 países se comprometieron a
frenar la deforestación para 2030 pero
no quedó claro cómo se vigilará ese
compromiso más de 40 países se
comprometieron a reducir el uso de
carbón pero quienes más lo consumen
países como eeuu china india o australia
no firmaron más de 100 países se
comprometieron a reducir en un 30% las
emisiones de metano para 2030 importante
medida porque el metano es responsable
de un tercio del calentamiento global
pero china-rusia e india- principales
productores no se adhirieron en cuanto a
la financiación privada el compromiso
también fue bajo
450 organizaciones que controlan 130
billones de dólares dijeron que
financiarán un cambio a las energías
limpias pero no quedó claro cómo lo
harán ni cuál sería el capital destinado
también hubo una inédita declaración
conjunta de china y eeuu los mayores
contaminantes del mundo que se
comprometieron a trabajar para reducir
el calentamiento global a 1,5 grados sin
embargo tampoco hubo una hoja de ruta
definida más allá de las promesas
y es suficiente todo esto la respuesta
corta es no aunque líderes y
organizadores defendieron lo pactado
expertos y activistas los acusan de
seguir pero castigando según el climate
action tracker incluso con el pacto de
glasgow vamos directo hacia un
calentamiento de 24 grados para finales
de siglo y que viene ahora en la lucha
contra el clima los expertos instan a
los países a seguir negociando durante
este año y volver el año que viene con
propuestas concretas y metas estrictas
al inicio de la cob 26 los organizadores
advirtieron que si este problema no se
tomaba en serio la ira del mundo sería
incontenible y tras su cierre ante lo
que muchos perciben como una falta de
voluntad para actuar la presión de las
calles y de los movimientos juveniles
que exige un futuro digno promete
hacerse cada vez más fuerte si les
sirvió el vídeo para entender lo
ocurrido en glasgow los esperamos en
otro episodio de 5 minutos aquí en
france 24